pues a decir verdad me parece bien la
idea de que sigamos viendo integrales
que tengan que ver con sustitución
trigonométricas la siguiente integral es
la integral de 1 entre 36 más x cuadrada
diferencial de x y bueno en el descuento
cada vez que yo veo este tipo de
integrales no pienso en una sustitución
normal porque si pienso en la
sustitución normal nos salen este tipo
de integrales
cada vez que yo veo algo de la forma
cuadrada más ex cuadrada pienso en una
sustitución trigonométricas y de hecho
eso es lo que vamos a hacer una
sustitución trigonométricas pero en esta
ocasión no va a ser la sustitución
trigonométricas x igual a veces el seno
del ángulo teta en esta ocasión voy a
usar la sustitución trigonométricas x
igual a a veces la tangente del ángulo
teta y porque bueno antes que nada lo
que a mí me gusta cuando yo veo este
tipo de integrales es que me quedara de
la siguiente manera lo que me va a
gustar es que en lugar del 36 veamos un
1 y para eso lo que voy a hacer es
factorizar el 36 por lo tanto me queda
la integral de de equis arriba 1 por de
x de x y abajo voy a factorizar el 36
que multiplica a su vez a 1
después multiplica a x cuadrado entre 36
dense cuenta que estas dos expresiones
son exactamente lo mismo sin embargo si
tienen una diferencia sustancial la
diferencia más importante de estas dos
expresiones es que en la segunda
expresión tenemos esta forma de aquí uno
más algo elevado al cuadrado por lo
tanto es aquí cuando se me ocurre hacer
mi cambio de variable a la tangente pero
antes de hacer mi cambio de variable
hacia la tangente del ángulo quiero
recordar una de las identidades
trigonométricas más importantes que hay
esta dice uno más la tangente cuadrada
del ángulo es igual a y si no se
acuerdan pues vamos a resolverlo lo
primero que voy a hacer es pasar la
tangente a términos de senos y cosenos
por lo tanto la tangente es lo mismo que
el seno entre coseno y eso me queda uno
más el seno cuadrado entre el coseno
cuadrado pero uno lo podemos escribir
exactamente igual que el coseno cuadrado
de un ángulo entre ese mismo coseno
cuadrado de un ángulo por lo tanto se
sacó factor común me queda el coste no
cuadrado de un ángulo más el seno
cuadrado de ese mismo ángulo entre el
coseno cuadrado de ese ángulo y bueno
coseno cuadrado más en el cuadrado de
teta es lo mismo que 1 por lo tanto al
final me queda
1 entre el coste no cuadrado de teta lo
cual es la secante cuadrada de teta
recuerden que 1 entre el coche no es la
secante y como está elevado al cuadrado
me queda la secante cuadrada del ángulo
teta y bueno todo esto para que lo estoy
haciendo porque yo lo que quiero es que
uno más x cuadrada entre 36 sé lo mismo
que uno más la tangente cuadrada de teta
o dicho de otra manera
x cuadrada entre 36 tiene que ser lo
mismo que la tangente cuadrada de teta y
es justo el cambio de variable que voy a
hacer por lo tanto lo voy a escribir
aquí abajo x cuadrada entre 36 quiero
que sea igual a la tangente cuadrada de
teta y si estas dos expresiones son
iguales por lo tanto yo puedo sacar raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados es decir me
queda que x entre 6 es lo mismo que la
tangente del ángulo teta y bueno si yo
despejo de aquí a x me queda que x es
igual a 6 veces la tangente del ángulo
teta antes de que se me olvide lo
primero que voy a calcular es la
diferencial de x con respecto a teta y
esto es igual a 6 veces la derivada de
la tangente de teta con respecto a teta
acuerdan cuál es la derivada de la
tangente de teta bueno yo tampoco muchas
veces tengo un poco de lagunas mentales
y por lo tanto me gusta calcularlo y
este procedimiento que voy a hacer es
justo si no se acuerdan entonces primero
lo voy a escribir aquí y después voy a
calcular la derivada de la tangente de
teta aquí abajo me queda seis veces la
derivada con respecto al ángulo teta de
la tangente de teta y bueno como no nos
acordamos que eras la derivada de la
tangente de teta con respecto a teta lo
voy a calcular aquí abajo la derivada
con respecto a teta de la tangente de
teta pues es lo mismo que calcular la
derivada con respecto a teta del seno de
teta entre el coste de nueve teta sin
embargo puede ser que tampoco te
acuerdes cómo calcular la derivada de
una división entonces lo que se hace en
esos casos es pasar el coche no hacia
arriba elevado a la potencia menos 1 es
decir quiero calcular la derivada con
respecto a teta del seno de teta por el
coche no detecta elevado a la menos 1 y
bueno ahora tengo una derivada de una
multiplicación de funciones y está
derivada va de la siguiente forma 1º
derivemos la primera función que es la
derivada del seno lo cual es el coste no
de teta y lo multiplicamos por la
segunda función tal
sin derivar entonces me queda el coche
no detecta que multiplica al cos en 9
teta elevado a la menos 1 y dese cuenta
que estoy poniendo este menos uno afuera
del paréntesis que tengo aquí porque si
no sería el coche no menos uno de teta y
podría confundirse con la operación
contraerá el coseno y después a esto hay
que agregarle la derivada del segundo es
decir la derivada del coseno al dt está
elevado a la menos 1 y multiplicarlo por
el primero pero quiero la derivada del
coste no de teta elevado a la menos 1
pues esto es bajamos el signo me queda
menos 1 ponemos coseno elevado a la
menos 11 es decir a la menos 2 kos en la
menos dos de teta después lo
multiplicamos por la derivada de lo que
está dentro es decir por la derivada del
coste no de teta y las derivadas del
coste no de teta es el menos seno de
teta por lo tanto todo esto lo vamos a
multiplicar por el menos en nueve teta y
lo único que estoy haciendo es aplicando
la regla de la cadena por lo tanto al
final hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de lo que está dentro y después
hay que multiplicarlo por la primera
función es decir por la función seno de
teta y ahora sí que me queda de todo
esto bueno primero tengo coseno beteta
que multiplica
es decir esto es lo mismo que cocino
beteta entre coste 930 que es 1 y ahora
en la siguiente expresión tengo menos x
menos me da más y después tengo coseno
elevado a la menos 2 que a su vez
multiplica a seno de teta por ciento de
teta es decir esto es lo mismo que éste
no cuadrado de teta / coseno cuadrado de
teta y se dan cuenta esto es justo lo
que tengo aquí arriba esto es lo mismo
que uno más la tangente cuadrada de teta
o dicho otra manera
justo lo que calcula la secante cuadrada
del ángulo teta entonces acabo de
probarles que la derivada de la tangente
de teta es ni más ni menos que la
secante cuadrada de teta y estuvo bien
padre porque logramos probar la derivada
de la tangente de t está usando la
derivada del seno de teta entre el coche
no de teta y sustituyendo me va a quedar
que la derivada con respecto a teta de
la tangente de teta pues es la secante
cuadrada de teta entonces ahora si
obtengo que la diferencial de x es lo
mismo que seis veces la secante cuadrada
de teta por la diferencial de teta esto
ya he visto en su forma diferencial y
ahora sí ya tengo la diferencial de x ya
tengo mi cambio de variable x es igual a
6 veces
gente de teta y por lo tanto ahora puedo
sustituir en un integral original pero
antes de dar el paso cósmico de
sustituir el integral voy a despejar la
teta el ángulo teta es igual al arco
cuya tangente es x entre 6 y bueno ahora
sí ya tengo todo despejado a ekiza de x
y el ángulo teta y por lo tanto voy a
despejar me queda que de x es igual a
seis veces la secante cuadrada de teta
diferencial de teta y abajo me queda 36
que multiplica a uno más
x cuadrado entre 36 es decir 1 más la
tangente cuadrada del ángulo teta justo
para eso hicimos este cambio de variable
por eso me queda en el denominador 36
que multiplica a 1 más la tangente
cuadrada de teta ahora bien se cuenta
que todo esto que tengo aquí es la
secante cuadrada de teta para eso
hicimos la identidad trigonométricas que
calculamos al principio del vídeo y
entonces secante cuadrada que multiplica
y secante cuadrada que divide se van 6
entre 36 me queda un sexto de la
integral de la diferencial de teta y
esto ya es muy sencillo resolverlo la
soluciones integrales un sexto de teta
más la constante de integración
pero queremos todo en términos de x por
lo tanto no hemos acabado hay que hacer
la sustitución hacia atrás y por lo
tanto voy a poner a theta en términos de
x es decir me va a quedar un sexto que
va a multiplicar a theta pero te estás
el arco tangente de x entre 6 más mi
constante de integración y ya lo hemos
resuelto realmente no nos quedó nada mal